la partie était à la croisée des chemins
jouets littéralement son avenir les
membres étaient confrontés à deux
options celle de la continuité ou celle
du changement ce soir les membres ont
tranché ce sera le changement le
renouveau et l'esprit d' aventure qui
animera le parti québécois au cours des
prochaines années
vous voyez l'avocat paul st pierre
plamondon qui est devenu le nouveau chef
du parti québécois
élu au troisième tour devant le député
sylvain gaudreault l'humoriste guy
nantel l'historien frédéric bastien mais
il est avec nous ce matin bonjour
bonjour la deuxième chef du parti
québécois après une longue course qui a
commencé en début d'année suspens en
raison de la coved 3 débat virtuel donc
élue hier soir ça a été quand même pas
mal d'émotion tout ça j'imagine vraiment
beaucoup d'émotion et puis si steam
c'est très fort ysance comme un honneur
j'ai 43 ans
je ne suis pas député j'ai fait campagne
sur le changement sur un vent de
renouveau au parti québécois et les
membres m'ont donné le feu vert et ça
laisse donc vraiment beaucoup de
possibilités c'est comme si on écrit un
nouveau chapitre dans l'histoire du
parti québécois puissent enseignement
c'est quoi ce changement là bas c'est
dire
on voit s'assumer pleinement on se
repose dans les tactiques on va y aller
de manière la plus transparente la plus
honnête possible
nous croyons sincèrement qu'on serait
mieux si on avait notre propre pays qui
avait pas un gouvernement de trop qui à
même nos impôts décide mais pas toujours
en fonction de nos intérêts on croit la
langue française on croit à la lutte aux
changements climatiques on a des choses
à proposer
non nous avons beaucoup de travail mais
ce travail mais en même temps dans une
position où on n'a rien à perdre et tout
à gagner
donc les prochaines semaines vont être
très très excitant donc seymour
inforizon c'est comme ça je me sens ce
matin même si j'ai pas dormi de la nuit
ou presque - j'imagine
vous avez parlé de québec d'un pays où
vous vous engagez à faire un référendum
lors d'un premier
sauf que vous n'êtes pas sans savoir que
les québécois en majorité n'en veulent
plus de cette option là vous pensez être
en mesure de raviver cette flamme
je pense que les québécois en majorité
savent que en soit le projet de pays
c'est une bonne idée
c'est comme idée qui légitime et devant
déclin de la langue française ne décline
aussi culturelles économiques au sein du
canada je pense que il y aura de
l'espace pour réhabiliter ce projet de
société devant aussi tous les échecs
répétés de la cac
durant la crise que vdu en général
chaque demande de québec envers ottawa
se termine par un nom par un refus donc
moi je certains noms si je peux me
permettre mais ce cinquième plamondon
aux dernières élections et pq qu'à
glisser on retrouve rang de troisième
parti de l'opposition derrière les
libéraux derrière québec solidaire
qu'est ce que vous allez pouvoir faire
pour vraiment et souffrit du nouveau là
pour assurer la survie du parti
j'étais très honnête tout au long de la
campagne avec mon lift s'attelle rebâtir
le camp du oui
donc c'est un parti rebâtir sur la base
de nos idées fondamentales les plus
fortes et donc si nos idées sont
toujours pertinentes dont celle de faire
un pays dont le nationalisme a su me
convenait de l'avant dont la lutte aux
changements climatiques si ces idées là
sont toujours pertinentes et le
gouvernement actuel ne les assume pas
n'agit pas de manière cohérente l'espace
pour le parti québécois il y en a
amplement donc la positionnement dans le
dernier sondage dans le prochain sondage
ce n'est pas la mentalité dans laquelle
ont mis en ce moment on n'a rien à
perdre tout à gagner un nouveau chapitre
un nouveau chef et j'ai fait campagne
sur le changement et chacun des
changements que j'ai proposé je vais
tenir parole je vais tenir promesse et
vous avez envie de faire tout ce travail
de construction ou de reconstruction à
l'extérieur de l'assemblée nationale pas
question pour l'instant d'aller tenter
d'avoir un siège comme rené lévesque le
fait en 77 76 comme jacques parizeau
également le fait être à l'extérieur de
l'assemblée nationale ça donne du temps
ça donne la disponibilité auprès de la
population
ça donne aussi l'idée
la possibilité d'innover de changer la
manière plus d'ailleurs la crise
sanitaire nous oblige beaucoup à sortir
des sentiers battus attendez-vous de ma
part à ce que ça sorte des sentiers
battus à ce qu'on trouve de nouvelles
manières pour dialoguer avec la
population put défendre nos gens parce
que dans le cadre de cette crise que vit
de ce que je remarque également c'est
que la confiance des gens envers nos
institutions et nos gouvernements sont
plus bas et ça prend un parti québécois
proche de son monde à la défense de son
monde notamment sur la transparence
parce qu'on a besoin d'un gouvernement
transparent lorsqu'on demande des
sacrifices
lorsqu'il ya des incertitudes dont il ya
des luttes à mener à très court terme
que le parti québécois sous ma gouverne
faut mener
elles sont importantes et donc
extraparlementaire c'est une bonne
position pour être très présent très
proche des gens pour aller travailler à
rassembler aussi les gens au sein de
votre propre parti a également on vous
entendu hier soir tendre la main à vos
opposants dans la course à la direction
également aux souverainistes qui ont
quitté le parti québécois au cours des
dernières années
en terminant est-ce que vous avez choisi
votre chef parlementaire
en fait j'ai eu des discussions lors il
y seulement 8h21
ç'a eu lieu hier soir donc édition
commence d'ici 24 à 48 heures chacune
des positions
l'organigramme en soi va être votre
confirmé donc laissez moi un peu plus de
temps mais comme vous dit je veux
revenir sur votre point essentiellement
tous ceux qui sont d'accord avec l'idée
de pays sont bienvenues parti québécois
donc les portes sont grandes ouvertes et
il ya un nouveau cycle s'amorce donc je
demande aux gens de surveiller ce qui va
se passer parce que c'est vraiment un
nouveau cycle qu'on débute et donc comme
chef parlementaire vous avez déjà eu des
discussions sur keith haring choix tout
de suite après le discours j'ai commandé
ces déductions j'étais sur le téléphone
puis-je content de voir d'ailleurs que
les députés sont positives de bonne
humeur prête à travailler donc ça
regarde très positive alors on va suivre
ça simplement d'un nouveau chef du parti
québécois merci beaucoup merci moi